même niché au coeur du village elle sait
rester discrète
la société fromagère de vercel propriété
du groupe lactalis source de richesse et
d'inquiétude la faute un bassin de
rétention des eaux qui n'existe pas
malgré les multiples relances des
services de l'état dans un communiqué le
groupe qui se dit pleinement conscient
de sa responsabilité environnementale
précise concernant vers celles les
travaux de réalisation d'un bassin de
confinement sont en voie de finalisation
pour une mise en service dès octobre
mais ce sont bien les rejets des unités
du groupe qui préoccupe l'état avait
recèle pourtant on assure que tout est
sous contrôle
les eaux usées du poids lourds de
l'emploi local par tout dans une station
surdimensionné tous les mois nous avons
compte rendu de la pollution des baies
euros tous les mois
tous les mois on sait ce qui pollue on
sait qu'elle fromagerie polluent et
depuis des années des fromageries pollue
de moins en moins mais elles polluent
encore dans le doubs huit sites sur les
95 en activité ont fait l'objet de mises
en demeure l'an dernier des injonctions
qui ont leurs limites importune au
moment où les mesures édictées par le
donneur demande du temps
oui il y a encore des situations qui
reste à améliorer
toutefois certaines situations et pu ont
pu amener à aller plus loin et à arrêter
certains satin satin rouge est où ils
veulent aller où les orienter vers
d'autres associations pour les
situations les plus les plus complètes
sont aujourd'hui non résolus non les
collectifs de défense de l'environnement
sont loin d'être aussi catégorique qui
constate des manquements réguliers sur
le terrain comme h entrant il ya
quelques mois un flux nauséabond en
provenance de la fromagerie monin est
directement connectée à la loue une
situation fitial mans résorber les
rejets aurait été ramené aux limites
légales autorisées
c'est à dire qu'on calcule un taux de
dilution et on considère que le milieu
récepteur est capable de digérer la dose
dépollution de pollution qu'on lui
envoie encore en pratique les rivières
aujourd'hui elle n'en peuvent plus elles
reçoivent tellement de pollution
ils ont dépassé leurs capacités d'auto
épuration et elles sont en train de
s'effondrer
donc la réalité des lits station
d'épuration le principe même des
stations d'épuration si un permis de
polluer passe à l'état qui se veut plus
sévère le collectif réclame un
changement radical des pratiques
une position qui lui a valu de se voir
accusé d'hagrid aching par le dernier
préfet
[Applaudissements]